my wrapping up comments would be this I
recently went out to dinner with five
close friends of mine who of which you
know most of them just like the crew the
wuang clan yeah just good friends and
one of the things I did is I I went
around the circle and I said a few words
of gratitude and I think to my earlier
point one of the things that's really
important to me after coming out of this
therapy is just this vulnerability that
allows us to speak from the heart
because we don't know what tomorrow
brings and I just want to say that Tim
you have been a friend of mine for so
long now and I have
appreciated the fact that my career has
been a series of ups and downs and all
over the place and you have been a
steadfast friend someone that sends me
some of the funniest videos I've ever
seen in my life always keeps it like
light-hearted and fun but I know that
you care deeply about me and I just want
to let you know that I love you and I
care deeply about you and I will always
be here to have your back and I'm
wishing you a fantastic New Year I hope
that you hit all these milestones and
more that you want to hit because I know
that you are someone that I've always
looked up to and someone that is just so
inspirational to us all that listen to
your show and your podcast because you
inspire us to do more and to be better
humans and I just want to let you know
that that's that means a lot to me and I
love you well thanks Kevin that's
amazing that makes my night and happy to
say it yeah it's the truth I love you
too man it's our friendship has been
such a such a constant for
me such
a Lifeline in a way with all the ups and
downs and holy [__] I mean both of us
have had some pretty wiy ups and downs
me you've had a lot of hot chicks you've
did I didn't see that coming yeah well
you talked about the upside Downs I was
like you've had a lot of UPS my friend
yeah I mean yeah i' look that's one
category that's a one category had to
lighten up the moon a little bit and I'm
and I'm and I'm grateful for that and uh
you know life is like box of chocolates
right you just never know what's around
the corner it's true it's true that's
why it's important to say these things
you know it is it is and you know I have
I have I'll tell you something you don't
know I have your Christmas slne Year's
card from like two years ago so
obviously out a date it's like you and
Daria and the kids and it's up in my
kitchen amazing and I kept it there cuz
I just I love seeing you guys every day
and I think about you guys all the time
and just have such love for your family
and I'm so grateful for our friendships
I love you too man it's important to say
things are so uncertain and I've never
experienced I've had friends pass from
cancer before yeah but I've never been
with them through I've I've never been
there every step of the way from
diagnosis to last conversation a few
days before they passed that was new for
me yeah and it affected really deeply
affected me on a bunch of
levels and I want to be deeply affected
by that right I I I want I don't want to
push that aside in part because Roland
was
so joyful
and
curious and optimistic until the end in
a very genuine way it wasn't an act it
wasn't
theater that raised a bunch of
aspirations in me right because he was
first and foremost a very dedic ated
season
meditator psychedelics were a piece of
the puzzle but first and foremost he was
a dedicated meditator for decades that's
amazing and attributed a lot of his
equinity
and preparation for death which I got to
see firsthand a lot of people talk about
it right but let's be honest or I'll be
honest I've read all the stoics or a lot
of the stoics and I've read all sorts of
Buddhism
and rehearse death and momento Mor and
this said the other thing but when I'm
actually on as Roland said the final
Glide path I don't know how I'm going to
respond I don't know I have no idea so
to see someone who really like walked
the walk in such a life affirming way
that Lit everyone up around him was was
tremendous and he said what he was able
to and he was willing to say what he
meant to those people around him who
meant things to him
and you don't have to wait until you
have termal cancer diagnosis you
shouldn't wait just because it may not
be that right it may be a car crash it
may be something where you don't get the
chance to say these things and so I just
yeah it's important to do it now yeah
you got to do it great to see you man
yeah good to see you all right man happy
New Year excited for this is going to be
a oh don't you me off a little bit
cheers yeah cheers Budd um to to the new
year and and to all the listen out there
you know wishing you a happy and healthy
New Year and yeah I'm excited to
continue this new I mean it's always a a
new year of change a new year of change
and exploration I think the one thing
that you and I let's take a sip the one
thing that you and I have in common is
just this like lifelong pursuit of of
evolution yeah of of like figuring out
because there the the secret that no one
will tell you is no no matter how much
money you make no matter how much
success you have we're all still
figuring out and in ROM doss's words
we're all just walking each other home
well said man I'm going to leave it
there here we go cheers buddy happy New
Year happy early New Year and happy New
Year to everybody
listening and as always be just a little
Kinder than as necessary until the next
episode that applies to other people but
also applies to yourself take it easy
take it easy you know life is short but
life is long and we're all just figuring
it out and by the way as far as I can
tell you never really figure it out no
you don't so true so so true ctfo chill
the [__] out a little bit be a little
easier on
yourself